i adore that show so much and you're
probably getting
asked about the cancellation a lot and
like it breaks my heart to not be able
to experience certain storylines through
to the finish
but i think one of the things that has
kind of upset me most was hearing about
that open letter
about the representation on the show and
how that was being dealt with
and the fact that we're not going to get
to see that brought through to fruition
and actually
see the action that was taken when
something like that was bringing
broughton up so
just so we kind of like don't lose the
value of that just from your perspective
what was it like seeing your co-stars
you know share their voice on the matter
and then seeing the show runners and the
other folks involved actually
take their their uh stance on it and run
with it
yeah it was absolutely a a beautiful
thing you know it uh
full disclo like you know to be fully
honest about it i wasn't privy to
a lot of those conversations that were
going on behind the scenes like and
rightly so
because that really is not my place and
that those those conversations were
for those members of our cast to have
directly with our show runners and
directly with netflix
and i feel so proud of them
for making their voices heard i know
that it took
a lot of courage and any actor can tell
you
especially if you're still recurring on
a show
if you're not in the top three on the
call
sheet it it you can feel it can feel
very precarious
it can feel really dangerous to speak up
about anything
and i think that um what they did is
such a sign of the way things are
changing for the better
even though it didn't in the end it
ended differently than we thought but um
but not because of the actions that they
took
at all so i think it just took an
immense amount of bravery
for those women to come together and
have a really honest conversation about
how they were feeling
a really emotional and vulnerable
conversation
about how they were feeling but not just
that but also suggestions of how they
thought
the show could be changed for the better
and i also think
a lot of credit is owed to liz and carly
um for and i just admire them so much
for
always being the type of women who are
open to
growing and changing and learning and
admitting when they've made mistakes and
wanting to make the show better
and wanting to change perspectives and
you know it made me even more proud to
have worked with them and to have worked
on a show
you know that's not only uh you know has
a cast that's filled out by
brittany and siddell and suny and
shakira and kia and ellen who had the
courage to write that letter
um but also show runners who really
stand by what they say they stand for
and we're willing to make those changes
yeah
i mean if it's if it's gonna come to an
end but still make an
impression that way i'm kind of glad
that still got to happen and that still
got out there
yeah yeah i think so too and i think it
was meaningful
um to those women also to get that
closure in a different type of way to
to say let's we want to be really honest
and that we we did love our time working
on
the show but here is something that we
were really looking forward to having
happen
it's not going to happen in another
sense of closure
i mean what is it like for you not
getting closure for that character
because we were just
we were on the cusp of something that
was so important and so deeply
personal to her so is it difficult for
you to kind of close the book on that
and move on to other projects
i mean of course it's it's
it's so sad in one respect because
it's just my most favorite job i've ever
done and it was really
i think the way in which it's not sad
is in in just three seasons i already
had
i've gotten so much from the show when i
say the show was life-changing for me it
just
on every level on a personal level in
terms of my self-confidence my
relationship with my body
uh on a professional level getting to be
a number one on a show getting to direct
um you know as a leader
also to work with all these women it
inspired me to start
writing and producing like i just i
oh gosh there's a leaf blower happening
um
there was um there's so much that i that
i already got from it i feel like i got
to hone my acting with
incredible actors like betty gilpin who
you know
is also the love of my life and it's
like it brought me to my soul mates
in her and and also liz and carly who
hopefully i can work with again so
it would be it like feels so greedy to
be like and i need one more
um but of course it's sad i have such a
kinship
for my character ruth and especially her
relationships with
betty gilpin's character debbie and and
mark maron's character sam i was sort of
like
how are things going to end with those
two how is her story going to end and
and you know it's it's especially
bittersweet because i got to have those
conversations with liz and carly about
what
might happen over the course of the
season and we did shoot a couple
episodes that no one will ever see um
but oh gosh is this terrible for you
this sound actually don't hear it that
oh
good okay good because of my head blower
situation myself and it's not half bad
what i will say is this year
has put everything in perspective
hopefully for a lot of people i i think
this
this this pandemic this disease
these things that are happening um you
know
in our country and things with black
lives matter there are so many things
going on there are so many
important things going on that deserve
attention
i think that a lot of us are going to go
into next year feeling like
totally different people like i i feel
like i've already changed a lot
just in the span of the last eight
months given everything that we've gone
through as a country
and you know in quarantine and on a
macro and a micro
level within my own home and family and
things like that
so in that way i actually think it makes
it easier to move on because it also
doesn't feel
personal i i you know a lot of shows
are falling by the wayside because of
covet restrictions and expenses and the
danger of
trying to get back into production and
so
you know i i think that
i feel like i'll be ready to to move on
to something else